dear fellow citizens
what a year lies behind us
2020 something came over us that
the world had not expected a
previously unknown virus penetrates
our bodies and our lives
it hits us where we are most
human in close contact  in
a hug in conversation while partying the
virus turns normal behavior into a
risk and completely unfamiliar
protective measures are normal 2020 this year of
the pandemic was the year of learning we
had to react to a virus in the spring
that there was hardly any reliable
knowledge and information about it
we had to make decisions  meetings
that we could only hope at first
would turn out to be correct the corona virus pandemic was and
is a political social economic task of the
century
it is a historic crisis that
has imposed a lot on everyone and too much on some
i know that it takes tremendous trust
and patience from you  demanded and
continues to demand s  I would like to embark on this
historical feat of strength
for that I thank you from the bottom of my heart
at the end of this breathless year it
is time to pause and mourn
we as a society must not
forget how many
people have lost a loved one in the
last few hours without being able to be close to them
me  can't ease your pain
but i'm thinking of you tonight
i can only imagine how bitter it
must feel for those who
mourn the loss of a loved one because of corona or are struggling
with the after-effects of an illness
when from some
incorrigible the virus  is disputed
and denied
conspiracy theories are not only
untrue and dangerous they are also
cynical and cruel
towards these people 2020 was determined by concern
and
certainty at the same time but it was also a
year in which just as many
surpassed themselves without hanging it on the
big bell
that  the female doctors prove to us  and
nursing staff in hospitals,
nursing homes and other facilities
this can be seen in the employees of the
health authorities who have suddenly moved into the
center of the fight against the virus
. we see this in the enthusiasm of
our armed forces
, which provides support at every turn.
countless people have
contributed to that  our life was
still possible despite the pandemic
in the supermarkets and in
goods transport in the post offices in
buses and trains in the police stations
in the schools and day care centers in the churches
in the editorial offices
i am always grateful for
how disciplined the vast majority of
people wear their masks like  they
try to keep their distance
for me this expresses what makes
life in a philanthropic
society possible in the first place
consideration for others the
insight to take a step back from time to time
the awareness of community spirit this
attitude of millions of fellow citizens has
us  our previous path through the
pandemic saves a lot
it will also be necessary in the coming year
which gives me hope for a few days
now the hope has had faces it is not only the
faces of the first vaccinated the very
old and their nurses
of the medical staff in the
intensive care units  with us
but in all european and many
other countries
day by day there will be more step
by step other age and professional groups
will come along and then everyone who wants it
i will also get vaccinated when
it is my turn hope
the scientists worldwide will also let me
also in germany the
first reliable corona test was
developed here and now also the first
vaccine approved in europe and many countries around the world it
emerged from the
work of a german
company before jungs and is
now being manufactured as a german american
production
the founder uhr sahin  and sl  at the tournament
in mainz they told me that
people from 60 nations work in their
company
nothing could show better that it is
european and international
cooperation that is the power of
diversity that brings progress
the tasks that the pandemic poses and
remains huge for many
commercial workers solo
self-employed and artists are
insecure yes fear of existence
the federal government has not left them alone in these
emergencies through no fault of their
own state support
in an unprecedented amount is helping
improved short-time work rules take effect
jobs can be preserved in this way so
everything is corona in the new year too
no and that was it  even in the old
not only since the beginning of the pandemic
, the world we live in is changing
rapidly and fundamentally, it is all the more
important that
germany develops courageous ideas for the future with all its strength and creativity that
our economy  ten our mobility
our life climate is protected that all
people in germany can benefit from
equal living conditions and
real educational justice
that we can also hold our ground better with europe
in the globalized
digitalized world dear
fellow citizens these days and weeks are difficult because there is nothing to
sugarcoat  times for
our country
and it
will remain so for a while
it will still be up to all of us for a long time
how we get through this
pandemic winter is and will remain
hard we know what we can do to
counteract the virus the
most effective besides the vaccine  we have the means in our
own hands by sticking to the
rules each and every one of us all of us
together let me
say something personal
in closing the federal elections are in nine months
and i will not be standing in them again
this is therefore the most likely scenario today
after the last time i saw myself as
may the federal chancellor address you with a
new year's address i
think i'm not exaggerating when i say
never in the last 15 years have we
all felt the old year to be so difficult
and despite all
our worries and some skepticism we have never looked forward to
the new year with so much hope  seen
and so I wish you and your
families from the bottom of my heart health
confidence and god's blessing for the new
year 2021
[music]